is competition
good for the world you know this kind of
uh
seems to be one of the fundamental
engines of capitalism right
do you see it as ultimately constructive
or destructive for the world
what really matters is how good your
legal framework is so competition within
nature
you know for food leads to bloody
conflict all the time the animal world
is
quite unpleasant to say the least if you
have
something like the rule of law and
clearly defined property rights which
are
within reason justly allocated uh
competition probably is going to work
very well but it's not an
unalloyed good thing at all it can be
highly destructive military competition
right
which actually is itself sometimes good
but it's not good per se
what what what aspects of life do you
think we should protect from
competition so is there some you said
like the rule of law is there some
things we should uh
keep away from competition well the
fight for territory most of all
right so violence anything that involves
like actual physical violence
right and it's not that i think the
current borders are just i mean go talk
to
hungarians romanians you know serbians
bosnians they'll talk your ear off
and some of them are probably right but
at the end of the day we have
some kind of international order and i
would rather we
more or less stick with it if
catalonians want to leave
they keep up with it you know let them
go but what about space of like
healthcare
this is where you get into attention of
like between capitalism and
kind of uh morse i don't want to use
socialism but those kinds of policies
that are less
free market i think in this country
healthcare should be much more
competitive
so you go to hospitals doctors they
don't treat you like a customer
they treat you like an idiot or like a
child or someone with third party
payment and it's a pretty humiliating
experience often
yeah do you think a free market in
general
is possible like a pure free market
and is that a good goal to to uh strive
for
i don't think the term pure free
market's well-defined because you need a
legal order
the legal order has to make decisions on
like what is intellectual property
more important than ever there's no
benchmark that like represents the pure
free market way of doing things
uh what will penalties be how much do we
put into law enforcement
no simple answers but just saying free
market doesn't
pin down what you're going to do on
those all important questions so
free market is a is an economics i guess
idea so there's no
it's it's not possible for free market
to generate the rules they're like
emergent like self-governing it
generates a lot of them right through
private norms through trade associations
international trade is mostly done uh
privately and by norms so it's certainly
possible
but at the end of the day i think you
need governments to draw very clear
lines
to prevent it from turning into mafia
run systems
you